America might actually be ready for a
gay
president some people say we've had a
gay president or two but yeah
a new poll is showing that we might
actually be ready for this is by pew
Research Center for the people in press
let's take a look
the majority american 66 percent say it
wouldn't matter for presidential
candidate was gay
or lesbian night 27 percent say they
would be
less likely to support a gay or lesbian
candidate while 5 percent would be more
likely
and in 2007 nearly have said they would
be less likely to vote for a gay
well as being handed so doesn't really
surprise me that much a lot a good gay
stuff has been happening just last week
what we get that one of these activist
judges
they took down pennsylvania is now going
to gay marriage a roaring in
the so get good gay things are happening
what you have a segment called gay stuff
good
day stuff good games that you could be
the token straight guy
yeah to be president yeah
so no the ambassador for the lesbian
community at
you must feel good about this you can
our you can now be pressed I this is
actually
I actually planned this segment to take
a moment to talk to the american people
about my run
2014 I'm now I feel really excited about
that
a I like them gave no specifics about
your rather lead to be at that question
and it's gonna be good
it's gonna be a now I think I think is
very telling you where we're coming in
this country I think we've made huge
steps
we meet forward really in the past
couple years and I think now people are
realizing it doesn't matter
who you are you're probably gonna fuck
up the hey you know
like yeah I get it now we've had plenty
of straight Presidents
and they still manage to fuck yes good
hello
you know i mean bad now a better issue
your apology when I had to get great
yeah I think that's a good I think that
the joke that's why I have to be a
president yeah
here no he'd never going to get nothing
what about you
that can be there know that my campaign
slogan has
yeah hopefully we'll get jacked it here
yeah ok that go every
yeah oh man I'm by dealing with so I
think it's obviously great right
course it is so yes well maybe we'll
have a gay president probably within our
lifetimes fantastic
you think the biggest hurdle actually
will be the the public display of
affection
cuz that's still the part that is not
shown for gay people even though there's
been a huge
but you know it's really awkward to
watch most presidents be a for sure
like I mean I think Obama but there is
one that can I had likens flag with him
played a first lady yet but you know
George W Bush
that was where did like an awkward I'm
like what did their sec
way you remember the horrible al al gore
cast America got less al gore remember
that go agree with that that was two
thousand
yeah that one where it was like listen
I'm a row bob the actual
hell yeah paper down I
and he did and it was just so grows long
yeah and it was just strange
and I get that I mean and and there's
this
I don't think that anyone is being
edna's but those public displays of
affection regardless of gender like
I think those are still kinda creepy
know me and I think everyone finds I can
a middle ground where a bit like a
tasteless by then it's okay then it
stable but
it's how it's hard to find it headed to
have a one-third goes overboard you can
enter
yes sorry we're agreed that that's
pretty gross no matter who is giving
will be easier to have
a gay email or a lesbian
first at my gut feeling is you we
probably have a lesbian purrs
why whenever Hillary Clinton yeah that
was doing
I'm night it might be easier but then
where attacking
where of not only electing our first
woman but she really has been hey
again I'm ready rather than
yeah now I think it's possible I mean
I don't know I'm one hand they feel like
people will be more active
you know vote for man I don't know I
mean historically it's been the case but
I think people film more uncomfortable
saying that kinda great I just feel like
a committee abrasions are
uncomfortable having a gay leader back
whom
yeah I would always with the shower I
was up here way where are we as well
Hollywood where we go yeah I'm a
in a Justin Bieber that I'll on that
note that would get
up